>> CHINESE BUSINESS HAS
PENETRATED BIG PARTS OF THE U.S.
ECONOMY, THEY CONTROL MUCH OF IT
AND MANY AMERICAN COMPANIES NOW
HAVE CHINESE OWNERSHIP.
MATT GAETZ REPRESENTS FLORIDA
AND IS WORRIED THAT THE BAILOUT
WILL WIND UP ENRICHING THE
CHINESE AND HELPING THE CHINESE
GOVERNMENT.
THIS TELL US -- THANKS FOR
COMING TONIGHT.
TELL US WHAT YOUR CONCERN IS AND
HOW YOU PLAN TO ADDRESS IT.
>> RADISSON HOTEL’S, AMC MOVIE
THEATERS, EVEN THE
WALDORF-ASTORIA IN NEW YORK ARE
CONTROLLED BY CHINA IN ESSENCE
AND I THINK WE OUGHT TO RESTORE
EVERY AMERICAN WORKER AND
AMERICAN SMALL BUSINESS BEFORE
BORROWING MONEY FROM CHINA SO
THAT WE CAN THEN GIVE IT TO
CHINA TO THEN PAY CHINA BACK
WITH INTEREST AFTER THE CHINESE
VIRUS.
SEEMS LIKE A FOOLISH THING THAT
A GREAT NATION WOULD NEVER DO.
I’VE INTRODUCED LEGISLATION TO
BLOCK BAILOUTS TO CORPORATIONS
CONTROLLED BY CHINA.
IT IS SO OBVIOUS I CAN’T BELIEVE
IT’S NOT THE LAW ALREADY.
>> THEY ONLY SHOW PANDEMIC ON
THE WORLD AND WE SEND THEM TAX
DOLLARS.
WHY WOULD THAT BE A
CONTROVERSIAL THING TO PROPOSE.
>> CHINA HAS A LOT OF INFLUENCE
ON THE COMPANIES THAT SEEK
CHINESE INVESTMENT ALSO HAVE
THAT INFLUENCE BUT THIS IS A
TIME WE CAN ACTUALLY PUT AMERICA
FIRST.
THE NEEDS OF OUR PEOPLE IN OUR
BUSINESSES.
THIS SHOULD BE THE EASIEST TIME
IN THE WORLD TO MAKE SURE WE ARE
MAKING REINVESTMENT IN THE
AMERICAN ECONOMY AND THAT WE ARE
NOT THE WORLD’S FOOLS BY
BORROWING MONEY FROM A COUNTRY
IN THE BOND MARKET RECYCLING IT
BACK TO THEM AND THEN CHARGING
THE NEXT GENERATION OF AMERICANS
INTEREST ON THAT MONEY.
WE CANNOT DO THAT, CONGRESS
SHOULD INCLUDE MY NO CHINA ACT
AND THE ULTIMATE RELIEF PACKAGE.
>> ALREADY RECEIVED MEDICAID
FUNDING AND AT NO RISK OF GOING
UNDER.
IS THIS REAL, FOR ONE THING?
WHAT CAN REPUBLICANS DO ABOUT
IT?
>> THERE IS A NEVER ENDING LIST
OF THESE VIRTUES SIGNALING ITEMS
THAT THE LEFT IS TRYING TO PUT
INTO THIS BILL.
THEY USE THE CORONAVIRUS AS AN
OPPORTUNITY TO SEE THROUGH OUR
VISION OF THE COUNTRY.
CAN WE JUST FOR A MOMENT TAKE A
PAUSE AND TRY TO SOCIALLY
ENGINEER AMERICA AND ACTUALLY
GET RESOURCES IN THE HANDS OF
DESPERATE AMERICANS WHO ARE
WORRIED ABOUT HOW TO BUY FOOD
AND CLOTHING FOR THEIR CHILDREN?
>> LAST QUESTION, 15 SECONDS,
SENATOR RICHARD BURR KNEW ABOUT
THE CORONAVIRUS AND SAVED HIS
OWN PORTFOLIO INSTEAD.
IS HE GOING TO STAY IN THE
SENATE DO YOU THINK?
>> RICHARD BURR IS A DISGRACE.
HE SHOULD BE REMOVED AS THE
INTELLIGENCE CHAIRMAN
IMMEDIATELY AS A RESULT OF THIS
CONDUCT AND AS REPUBLICANS IN
THE TRUMP ERA, WE HAVE AN
OBLIGATION TO SAY WE DO NOT WANT
CORRUPT ACTS TO BE ASSOCIATED
WITH OUR TRIBE AND REPUBLICANS
NEED TO START STEPPING UP AND
SPEAKING OUT BECAUSE WHAT
RICHARD BURR DID IN THE SENATE
STOCK SELL-OFF IS NOT SOMETHING
THAT WE WANT OUR BRAND
ASSOCIATED WITH.
>> GOD BLESS YOU FOR SAYING